[Música]
rusia afirma que tomó la ciudad de
mariupol luego de anunciar que ya no
queda ningún combatiente en la acería a
su hostal este viernes hubo una última
ronda de rendiciones y antes el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
le ordenó a sus tropas que abandonaran
la planta para salvar sus vidas
se mantiene la ley antiinmigratoria de
eeuu conocida como título 42 un juez
federal de luisiana impidió que el
gobierno de joe biden anular la norma y
respaldo a los estados que demandaron la
medida bajo el argumento de que sin el
título aumentarían los migrantes
un nuevo episodio del enfrentamiento
entre la iglesia católica y el gobierno
de nicaragua
el obispo rolando álvarez inició una
huelga de hambre tras denunciar que la
policía lo siguió y que ha hostigado a
más religiosos adicionalmente las
autoridades cancelaron el canal católico
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle y es un
placer estar con ustedes iniciamos
hablando de la guerra en ucrania porque
rusia dijo que ya controla completamente
mariupol en lo que sería su mayor
victoria hasta ahora el ministerio de
defensa ruso afirmó que el último grupo
de 531 personas en la planta siderúrgica
de azov tal se rindió más temprano el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
anunció que les pidió a los combatientes
que salieran de la fábrica y salvaran
sus vidas ha sido un símbolo de la
resistencia de ucrania ahora la planta
de acero de asof tal parece estar bajo
control ruso moscú afirma haber
capturado en la ciudad portuaria de
mariupol tras la rendición del último
grupo de 531 combatientes de la acería
que ha sido escenario de feroces
combates y bombardeos durante varias
semanas
las construcciones subterráneas de la
planta donde se escondía el alicante han
pasado a estar bajo el control total de
las fuerzas armadas rusas el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski dijo que se
había ordenado al regimiento a soft que
depusieran las armas unasur
hoy los muchachos han recibido una señal
clara de mando militar de que pueden
salir y salvar sus vidas me mantuvo con
el pavo
como los soldados ucranianos que se
habían rendido anteriormente ya llegaron
a la región de don jets como prisioneros
de guerra casi 2500 se han entregado a
las fuerzas rusas ya los separatistas
pro rusos desde el 16 de mayo según
moscú
[Música]
no logramos evacuar a los civiles y los
heridos recibieron el tratamiento médico
necesario en cuanto a los héroes caídos
el proceso está en curso
espero que los familiares y toda ucrania
puedan enterrarlos con honor en un
futuro próximo y modesto sistema poco
bate su hijo en el régimen tras off fue
formado como milicia por nacionalistas
radicales para luchar contra los
separatistas apoyados por rusia y
posteriormente pasó a formar parte de la
guardia nacional ucraniana ucrania ha
expresado su esperanza del intercambio
de prisioneros con los combatientes
rendidos pero las autoridades rusas han
amenazado con juzgar a algunos de ellos
por crímenes de guerra y cambiamos de
noticia porque por ahora seguirá vigente
en eeuu el controvertido título 42 la
medida anti migratoria que instauró la
administración de donald trump y con la
que restringía el ingreso de emigrantes
para evitar la propagación del cob y 19
un juez federal del estado de luisiana
dio la razón a varios estados que habían
demandado
el presidente de retirar la medida
el título 42 seguirá vigente hasta nuevo
aviso un juez de luisiana frenó los
planes de washington de levantar la
medida este 23 de mayo la política que
entró en vigor en el gobierno de donald
trump faculta a los agentes federales de
la frontera con mexico para devolver a
los migrantes sin posibilidad de
tramitar solicitudes de asilo mientras
en ciudades fronterizas de ciudad juárez
y tijuana en el norte de méxico esperan
impacientes a que se levante la medida
había mucha expectativa porque la
administración de bailén se había
comprometido a eliminar el título 42 el
23 de mayo pero eso se vio frenado en
una corte federal y pues lo más probable
es que no se va a eliminar el título 42
este lunes provenientes de cuba colombia
nicaragua venezuela y otras
nacionalidades de américa latina' cruzan
el río bravo con esperanza de llegar a
territorio estadounidense
a trabajar
seguiré el artido por sus hormigueros
el título 42 se puso en marcha en marzo
de 2020 al inicio de la pandemia con el
propósito de frenar el avance del cob y
19 desde entonces más de un millón de
inmigrantes detenidos en la frontera han
sido expulsados rápidamente a méxico u
otros países en virtud de la orden a
menudo a las pocas horas de ser
capturados en abrir los centros de
control de enfermedades de eeuu dijeron
que ya no era necesario el título 42
para luchar contra el convoy 19 debido a
la disponibilidad de vacunas pero los
estados de arizona luisiana misurí y
otros todos con fiscales generales
republicanos han demandado para evitar
que la administración baiden terminará
con la política mientras biden ha
recibido críticas de naciones unidas- de
10 miembros de su propio partido por no
actuar con rapidez rumbo a una esperada
política más humana con los viajeros
indocumentados
en nicaragua el obispo rolando álvarez
inició una huelga de hambre contra el
gobierno de daniel ortega y la inició
desde una iglesia en managua en la que
se refugia indefinidamente tras
denunciar seguimientos a él y
hostigamientos en contra de otros
religiosos en sus parroquias álvarez fue
uno de los mediadores de los fallidos
intentos de diálogo entre el gobierno y
la oposición en 2018 y ahora él afirma
que la policía invadió la casa de sus
familiares y agregó que sólo volverá a
consumir alimentos cuando sea
garantizada la seguridad de sus seres
queridos en una línea similar se
pronunció esta semana la arquidiócesis
de managua y precisó que seguirán
denunciando los abusos y acompañando a
los nicaragüenses en medio de las
acusaciones en contra de religiosos
señalados de traición a la patria
estamos viviendo una situación de terror
de tal manera que aquí no sólo
religiosos sacerdotes sino también
muchos nicaragüenses
la mayoría diría yo la inmensa mayoría
de los nicaragüenses vivimos en un
permanente hostigamiento nos claro que
se enfoca esto y se recrudecería en
persecución con algunas personas
específicas en noticias electorales de
colombia la franco-colombiana ingrid
betancourt retiró su candidatura
presidencial para apoyar a rodolfo
hernández quien sería el tercer
candidato más votado según las encuestas
recientes la candidata del partido verde
oxígeno era la única mujer que aspiraba
a ocupar la presidencia pero en los
sondeos no superaba el 1 por ciento de
la intención de voto betancourt volvió a
la carrera presidencial 20 años después
de haber sido secuestrada por la
entonces guerrilla de las farc cuando
era precisamente candidata en 2002
y terminamos en francia donde se estrena
el nuevo gabinete de los 27 funcionarios
13 son mujeres y 14 hombres con lo que
se respeta la paridad algunas de las
caras conocidas que se mantienen en sus
cargos son los ministros de economía
interior y justicia pero también hay
sorpresas
conservan la confianza de manuel macro y
se mantienen en su ministerio el
ministro de economía desde el inicio del
primer mandato de manuel macro bruno le
maire permanece en bercy también el
ministro del interior gerald arman en
bobo y aunque parecía que estaba de
salida el ministro de justicia eric supo
moët y mantiene su puesto pero se
conocieron asimismo nuevos miembros del
gabinete van a mccutchen columna
catherine con una ministra para europa y
asuntos exteriores y desde
éstas quizás la sorpresa de este nuevo
equipo de gobierno la llegada al
ministerio de exteriores de catering
colonna a sus 66 años fue anteriormente
embajadora en el reino unido y está
acostumbrada a hablar en nombre de
francia en la escena internacional
damián abad también abad ministro de
solidaridad de autonomía y personas con
discapacidad tome el de persona con
dicha se conoció también una figura que
atrajo la ira de los miembros de su
partido los republicanos al dejar la
presidencia del grupo el pasado jueves
damián abad se une a emanuel macrón
music pub
en día y ministro de educación nacional
y juventud y de los iones el director
del museo de historia de la inmigración
papel diet tendrá la pesada tarea de
aliviar las tensiones con la profesión
docente por su parte salen del gobierno
el ahora ex ministro de educación ya
michelle blanquea al igual que ella y le
dejan marlene si arpa o florence para
glee y sebastián le con quien asumirá la
jefatura de las fuerzas armadas hasta
ahora era el ministro de los territorios
de ultramar
olivier d'uixó ministro de trabajo pleno
empleo y de inserción club y donación
finalmente este ex socialista de 43 años
tiene entre sus misiones el objetivo del
pleno en 2027 fijado por enmanuel macrón
para su segundo quinquenio otra de las
promesas de campaña del presidente es la
transición ecológica y es a melide moi
sadam quien ha sido nombrada para este
puesto habrá que estar atentos el lunes
al primer consejo de ministros para ver
la primera foto de familia
hasta aquí las noticias sigan en france
[Música]